what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich russell's
trying to get our lunch money right it's
friday you know i got that trillionaire
energy
we're out here we're making moves i'm
here with pelina she's got
i don't know sailor outfit a prison
outfit whatever you want to call it do
not forget that
blockfi is now the sponsor of lunch
money that means if you go to
blockfit.com and you sign up for an
account
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange with no fees
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account or you
can deposit crypto and you can earn
or i'm sorry and you can get the us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you all thought i was gonna
make a mistake uh uh i don't make
mistakes
and neither will you if you go to block
five dot com slash
pomp blackfly.com let's get after it
what do you got for us
no starbucks or no christmas cup today
okay
do you know who's feeling the heat from
their employees
wall street banks are feeling the heat
they're trying to get closer to adopting
bitcoin because their employees are
pushing them too
the banking industry is forced to
contend with bitcoin as its latest
dizzying ascent
and increased adoption among investors
corporations and fintech competitors
spark
fears of being left behind jp morgan
co-president daniel pinto
said the demand isn't there but i'm sure
it will be
at some point everybody gonna have to
be getting in on [ __ ] tell them about
the miami mayor
listen my guy miami mayor francis suarez
working his butt off he's better working
working his butt off it looks easy but
it ain't easy
the guy's working and that's what i
appreciate about him so
he went and he got approval from the
city commission
on a 4-1 vote that they are now going to
do this big study
to hopefully allow for residents to pay
city taxes and bitcoin
pay city fees in bitcoin for city
employees to get paid a percentage
of their salary in bitcoin and for the
city of miami to take their treasury and
invest part of it into bitcoin
my guy is trying to make bitcoin uh to
make miami
the first municipal city that is bitcoin
enabled
we all gonna get into bitcoin the
companies are gonna do it the financial
institutions and now the cities and when
the cities do it the counties are gonna
do it the states are gonna do it and the
federal governments are going to do it
let's go
or as they say uh miami vominos
okay um bumble ceo whitney wolf heard
joined the tech industry's growing
billionaire class after her dating apps
explosive
ipo bumble stock price surged 63
to 70 and 31 cents uh making it the
latest tech darling to soar
on its first day of trading what do we
think
people are getting it's a buzzy ipo
i actually interviewed whitney a long
time ago like five years ago
uh for a uh it was a story about like
tinder i think because she was she
started at tinder and then she founded
bumble i know nothing about dating apps
i'm married
guys uh dating at
like space is huge go ahead it's very
saturated and when she started a bunch
of reporters because i was there thought
they shouldn't cover bumble because it
was the dating space was super saturated
but hey it worked and obviously
and she is now a billionaire and she
rang the bell with her little son
nah what i meant by the addressable
market is massive
everybody's looking for love he has let
me tell you
dating everybody is looking for love
that's what they want
they may think that they like the
partying they may think that they like
you know chilling by themselves they may
think that they like the fact that ain't
nobody up in their business yelling and
screaming at them all the time
they may think it's awesome that they
ain't got somebody like pelina being
like did you take the trash out yet
did you do this did you do that
sometimes you're like
but then you're like no you know what
everybody's looking for love
and speaking of love it's valentine's
day this sunday we hope that you guys
are spending it with your
new loved ones i knew that one time can
i just tell them
one time i come home and he like got me
a valentine's day gift
and legend legend status i remembered
and i got it
it's like my favorite chocolates right
legend i knew the favorite
legend wow this is so nice i didn't even
think you knew what year it was
so i go and i open it and there's a
chocolate missing one chocolate is
missing but the packaging is perfect and
i was like
there's a rat got into it at the store
or something i don't know i think
somebody
something must have gotten in there and
i was like stick it back and return it
anyway i snuck up in there real quick
she didn't even know
guys he doesn't even know but his
valentine's day present is arriving
today
and you'll find out what it is on monday
it's a great one
it is a great one all right
ready he's playing on his phone
sorry spotify will let employees work
from
anywhere after the pandemic spotify is
adapting a work from anywhere model
which will allow employees to choose
whether they want to be in office
full-time be at home full-time
or a combination of the two spotify has
i think
two offices it it has a presence in the
united states and a presence in sweden
so i think this is just kind of like but
what does working remotely do for
culture
in these companies what do you mean like
you you don't
really know your employees if i start
during the pandemic i've never met you
in person like how does it all work
we have multiple people that work with
us that we've never met in person
and the culture is great i just realized
you've never met matt and jordy in
person
that is crazy but you feel like you know
them yes you feel like there's a great
culture
yeah mainly because of the memes by the
way check out the memes on twitter we've
been firing away we might have more
dancing we may have more heat coming why
wasn't it going to talk you look like
one of those
flailing things in the parking lot okay
hyundai is working on a driverless car
that can also turn into a walking
machine i don't understand what that
means
but basically it's a concept vehicle
designed to function as both a
four-wheel drive car and a four-legged
walking machine
and the latest example of how ideas on
mobility and logistics are changing
so if you want something delivered maybe
it could drive to you and then walk to
your door and hand it to you
ow i hurt my elbow yesterday okay go on
her elbow's gonna be okay okay what did
you say tell me tell me what are you
let's go to the next one i i don't have
anything to say about
really no i don't and also their deal
with apple fell apart guys it's a big
deal
megan mark roll this is a big deal
meghan markle
um she sued a british media company aka
tabloid
that published parts of a letter she
wrote to her estranged father thomas
markle
and um the they ruled the high court in
london ruled
uh that it was unlawful
that that megan had a reasonable
expectation that the contents of the
letter would remain private and the
articles had
interfered with a reasonable reasonable
expectation i'm trying to get my brother
he's right here i'm trying to get him to
come say what's up real quick
you know the youngest one the the
prettiest one
the smartest one is right there meghan
markle
should go after them because guess what
she did go after them and she won
exactly and she should keep going after
them you know why because these people
think that they got
no they could just do whatever they want
there's no repercussion well guess what
now the subjects of the story got bigger
platforms
and they can go direct they are not
beholden
to dealing with your nonsense anymore so
if you all want to play the game
don't be mad when people clap back
she said and that's what she just did
she said for these outlets it's a game
for me and so many others it's real life
real relationships and very real sadness
the day the damage they have done and
continue to do runs deep
what this is this is what i'm saying she
thinks it's a game
i think that they're playing the game
and so guess what y'all want to play a
game cool
what happens when the subjects in the
story clap back
all right now that they got the big
audience now that they got the direct
relationship
now we ready to roll okay ask lunch
money time hashtag ask l
m daphne sun hi pomp and polly i watch
lunch money every day with my wife and
we love it we're also subscribed to the
profile and are enjoying it yay
um it's probably not gonna happen but
what do you think will happen if the fed
decides to peg the us dollar to bitcoin
i don't think that it'll happen but uh
they probably shouldn't do that
um i just don't see that occurring uh
i think that bitcoin will continue to
serve as kind of like a store of value
for
a considerable number of years and then
over time as
the volatility kind of uh is blended
down
and we get some some stability to uh uh
the us dollar price of it
uh then i think that's when you'll start
to see it really pick up as a medium of
exchange
um again you know i hope that doesn't
happen i hope it is a full acceleration
but i think if i just kind of look at it
rationally that's likely to be what
occurs and and finally day three
it was yesterday of moist commenting he
said thank you
everyone for your support hashtag moist
gang hashtag
unleash the moisture youtube is trying
to hold me back by not giving me a
notification today but i can't be
stopped
moist counter right here today is my
story where are we on day four
all right moist oh he's even putting in
there watch i don't know is it a guy or
a girl i don't know
uh day three of commenting i appreciate
it yo moise for day four leave a little
fact about yourself down there so we can
start to get to know you i want to
fact the day on top of this so not only
do i want the like but i want a little
fact of the day yeah we're going to
learn a lot about moist over the next 90
days tell me something interesting about
you
all right guys bang bang
everybody looking for love stop telling
them to play these games i'll see y'all
on monday
what bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click
on i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest
on an interest-bearing account or you
can buy and sell cryptocurrencies on
their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling
in the comments and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends